people are gross especially when they  eat slow chips I love chips oh oh no I'm  grossed out for some reason I just find  it oh very uncomfortable this feels so  intimate I hate everything right now no  no no I like that like the poppy  [Music]  sounds terrible oh okay that's the  hummus and the carrots just the graphic  of it is pretty Oh God  closer now it's more of the visuals that  got me rather than the sounds really  actually it's both I feel like I want to  throw up I always wondered why dates  were like food related because ill how  we just met  gross there's just a lot of people  eating with their mouths open and you  know society tells you to close your  mouths  [Music]  [Music]